mr. president the plane that went down
yelling from Iran whatever I think
happened to that plane well I have my
suspicions it was very I don't want to
say that because other people have those
suspicions also it's a tragic thing when
I see that it's a tragic thing but
somebody could have made a mistake on
the other side could have could have
made a mistake it was flying it was it
was flying in not our system now how
does nothing to do with us it was flying
in a pretty rough neighborhood and
somebody could have made a mistake some
people say it was mechanical I
personally don't think that's even a
question personally so we'll see what
happens
I don't know I really don't know I don't
want to get that's up to them at some
point they'll release the black box
ideally they'd get it to Boeing but if
they gave it to France or if they gave
it to some other country that would be
ok too I think you know ideally that
will be released I have a feeling that
it's just some very terrible something
very terrible happened very devastating
you